basically it's a straight shooting sort
of conversation but I think that
sometimes we get distracted and we talk
about the bigger because between men and
women I think that the problem that men
and women have is the consequences of
the bad decisions that the one percent
of powerful men make on our behalf
because our problems are on a societal
level less than between woman and man
that is why there's a lot of competition
between men this trace for status that
they will never get man why is that the
fault of the one person a man because
they're the ones that drive the machine
that runs this the Western it's always
been that way yeah and but then think
about them and at the top now the
corruption and everything that's going
on and this is why it feels very good to
sit next to somebody like you and just
say you know what I appreciate that you
say things that are really true you
expose a very toxic truth and a very
true truth as well that is out there but
the reality is on the trenches when you
go to the Grassroots people don't feel
the way that you feel it's not as simple
as what you say they are victims of this
system